AMIR HARDON: OK.
Hi.
I'm Amir.
I work on Flutter.
And I'm going to talk
about animation management
with Redux and Flutter.
And there's a talk
about Redux tomorrow.
And I'm not going to
go deeply into details
about how Redux works.
So if you're
interested in that, I
encourage you to
attend the Redux talk,
the application
architecture talk tomorrow.
OK.
The first thing I will say is
that there are many opinions
on how to do things out there.
And this is just
one more suggestion.
So not a silver
bullet, definitely.
OK.
I'm going to explain
this idea by walking
through an example
implementation of the "2048"
game.
Unfortunately, I
don't have enough time
to explain the game.
So if you don't
know the game, just
remember that the user picks
a direction, left, right,
up, or down.
And all the tiles slide
in that direction.
And some of them merge.
So this is how it looks
when I swipe right.
The tiles slide to the
right, and some tiles merge.
OK.
So we're going to implement
this with a Redux architecture.
And this is a very
typical Redux architecture
where the UI responds
to user events
by dispatching
actions to the store.
The store is where
we manage our state.
And the store responds to
actions by computing new states
and publishing these
states back to the UI.
And we're going to represent the
state for the game with a 4 x 4
integer matrix.
And we're implementing
four mutation operations--
move left, right, up, and down.
Here, we see a unit
test for the move right
operation, which is basically
what you would expect.
This is how we set the gesture
detector for our game board.
We basically say, when we
detected a horizontal drag,
we just need to figure out
what was that reaction, left
or right, and dispatch a
move left or move right
action to the store.
This is the only thing that
the UI is doing directly
in response to user
events, dispatching actions
to the store.
The next thing we need
to do is to wire our UI.
We get an update from the
store with a new state,
and we need to show
that on the screen.
Without animations, this
is pretty straightforward.
We just get the state
from the store update,
and we build a widget tree that
shows the board for that state.
Animations makes this a
little bit more complex.
And this is what I'm
going to talk about.
So with animations
the last state update
is no longer enough
information to figure out
what we should be
showing on the screen.
Given the rest
state, we don't know
which transition we
should be showing.
To deal with that, we
can add more information
with our store updates.
So in addition to
the current state,
we also include the previous
state and the action
that's triggered the update.
So that triplet is
enough information
to know which
transition we should
be showing on the screen.
So this is a snippet from
the build method of our board
widget.
We basically say, OK, we got
this triplet from the store.
We got the new
state, but we also
know the previous state
and the last action.
And we're going to
use that triplet
to build a new motion spec.
So this is the unit test for
our build motion spec method.
And the motion spec is basically
a description for which tile,
where it should
be going, what it
should be doing on the screen.
The next problem we have to deal
with are animation conflicts.
And an animation conflict is
when a transition to state D
is triggered while the
application is transitioning
between two other states.
I find it useful to
differentiate between two
kinds of transition states.
Real ones are when the
application is actually
waiting for something to happen,
versus cosmetic transitions,
like the animation
of the tiles sliding,
are just there to make the
user experience more smooth.
So this is what our UI code is
doing in response to a store
update.
It terminates any
ongoing transition.
It figures out which transition
it should be showing based
on the triplet it
got from the store,
and it fires and
forgets that transition.
Not exactly forget
it, because we still
need a way to terminate it
on the next store update.
So what happens when we
get an animation conflict?
So here you see how it looks.
When I swipe left,
everything is sliding.
And while it is
sliding, I swipe down.
So what we get is
this jump cut effect,
where the ongoing animation
is terminated completely
immediately, and
the next one starts.
And in this case, this is
actually a decent solution.
So this actually feels
responsive and natural
in this case.
And I argue that this is
a decent fallback for most
or many cosmetic transitions.
So to get that fallback, the
jump cut effect by default,
we need to make sure that
our UI code keeps a promise.
And that promise is that, given
that the last store update was
to state A, it is
either showing state A
or showing a
transition to state A.
Now, if you want more custom
conflict resolution, something
more fancy than the
jump cut effect,
you can still do that
by managing more state
in the presentation
layer in the UI.
Just make sure you
still keep that promise.
So this was quite a lot to
squeeze in five minutes.
So there's also a medium
article with more details.
And the example code
for the "2048" game
is available on GitHub.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]